hey what's up everybody Anna Mack here
for anime upper welcome to another rant
cafe stream and today we're doing the
long awaited insanely anticipated super
trigger warning stream debating who is
the best girl in boku no hero slash my
hero academia this is gonna be crazy
we've been doing it as a tournament art
you can see in the description link to
the bracket on the animal for Twitter
and joining me we have children talks
too much
Briggs from old anime the anime dude and
a monkey Lu yeah everyone's info is in
the description be sure to check him out
although I'm suspicious of Frankie
because his name sounds too much like
frothy but I feel like biased biased
we'll have to wait and find out but
first everyone the rule of this debate
is that we're gonna be judging best girl
based on personality no I say we do
everything like no - howdy person
trust me you can't do physical
appearance because some people are
really into frogs man they're just
really into frogs is very subjective so
I believe that we should do it based of
personality and we can bring up quark
psyche for quark it's cool
okay I'm down with that that make sure
that makes her a very cool character
because she has this specific work
that's cool but we can't just be like
him oh this one's harder because if that
was the case then snake hero above me
would win for sure I heard that because
I always go based best girl based on a
personality more anything anyway so yeah
yeah I thought you weren't gonna count
quirks I'm like this is my hero academia
you got a count daddy but you have to
give him a reason not just like Oh Kirk
work is badass like okay so well Momo's
quick Henry huh damn okay that kind of
takes away from a couple of the
characters that I was gonna be like but
this though I'm like okay okay boobs man
want it guys gonna be like Boop but
she's pink like
the first rounds hired man
first rounds very high thank you for
making by the way thank you guys for
making the bracket Briggs always makes
the bracket usually so I don't know and
once the hand we're thankful to him on
the other he can get all the hate or if
people like why did you match up this
with this at the first dude that's so
hard
simply questionable honestly I put like
very little thought into this bracket
but so what started off the first and
yeah but we have 16 best girls in the
bracket we did do not have some minor
characters that appear in like one
episode or one or two chapters briefly
then I'm sure before they're still gonna
be talking about who goes mom what isn't
because she was in one episode guys I
was gonna put her against that Guzman
why bubble girl bear why that one girl
from that froakie filler episode best
snake girl yes obviously you want me as
best snake girl let's just that's not
even okay alright so yeah this is gonna
be fun guys in the chat be sure to shot
along and freak out and get triggered
it's gonna be fun
this is gonna be super triggering yeah
this is gonna be if you prepare
yourselves prepare your bodies because
this is going to be and again as always
the rules are that there's five of us
three whoever gets three votes wins
you can argue for one person or the
other but at the end it's majority rule
about who is best girl and first round
first round we have Mina Ishida versus
to you Ashley tough one boys why that
actually is a tough first round man I
don't know who likes a she don't like I
do
who doesn't what's dude from peas like
easy baby
she's a frog she's an adorable frog but
mean is also an adorable bug Mina has to
be more
refer to as alien queen like in in our
hearts that is so aliens are queens I
don't want to hear any other hero names
for Nina
except alien queen but yes or who also
start us off either girl you wanna argue
for I'm gonna be the swing vote I think
this is really hard I like them bully
what is choose like clerk dislike being
a frog like doing thing frog like things
I gotta even know do you guys actually
knows quark like stuff right she can
also like surf on the acid from what I
remember yeah yeah yeah she could also
use that I think to climb stuff do
because she can melt like stuff that
climate um so you can obviously use the
agility olefrog she has the tongue she
has the like the gross spit stuff she
does right so if she can like keep stuff
in her stomach in and vomit at all I
feel like I'd rather have Mina as like a
wife over yeah like so you would be very
caring for you but me
you know would be hey man like let's go
out to the beach or like let's go out
and do stuff like Mina would be the one
to like get you outside like if you were
to be with I don't understand people's
fascination with to you to be honest I'm
gonna vote for Mina love curious I know
with a Frankie Frankie
I really thought she's gonna win this
whole thing honestly I wasn't gonna vote
for her to win the whole thing but it's
like I just what's your like support as
to why you like to you I got underside
own understand the hype I want it like
I'll try to understand it I do get the
hype but I just I mean she's like really
down-to-earth character I don't know no
character she's also received like the
most screen time out of like any of the
girls so far she's thinking and she just
kind of tells people off by doing that
getup that little [ __ ] like getup
she's just cute like froakie is she's
cute but she's also like tough enough to
like be in the thick of it with like the
rest of the class and she's able to kind
of handle her own
she's very I thought she was gonna end
up with deku like it drink season one
like I was like okay so like maybe
ochico is like just like his first crush
but for real [ __ ] my swerved I ship to
you with Nina you remember that yeah
yeah it was Jay seem guys yeah I was
like holy God
yeah but uh in terms of like my own
feelings so we have by the way one vote
for Mina for breaks yeah she's a more
like a shy sort of like down-to-earth
carabiner she's you know she does care
about friendship a lot that type of
stuff whereas mean eyes are more of an
outgoing popular girl type character
more girly so yeah like they both have
their own certain personality they're
both seem to be very sincere and kind
and care about their friends yeah cuz
that's the thing right because like with
frou pea like you know that she'll have
your back but you'll also tell you it
like it is like I don't really want to I
guess we get like it's but the anime is
free to spoil I guess right yes
okay so if ropey straight-up tells the
gang like don't go after baka go that's
breaking the rules and you be villains
like and she does feel bad about it
later but she tells them what she
thought they needed to hear at that
moment so I think froakie would be like
on one hand froakie is much more like
you know what it is it's the it's like
the video game Kathryn where it's like
one's very responsible in kind of more
shy in the end and the other girls like
crazy and wants to go have fun and blah
blah blah
it's basically Kathryn but I honestly as
much as I like froakie I have to go with
Meena she just she's so fun and cool and
like I don't know if she's just bubbly
and happy and and she's pink
she's bang you got you know it's like
the type of girl in high school you
would want to be friends with yeah
because you're rather of being an anime
for example clearly would never happen
yeah yeah yeah I gotta go Minah
I'm sorry yeah I'm also torn because
personally I didn't I didn't
with sujes logic like I like you you
made a good point about her being upset
about them going to rescue Paco but I
didn't agree with that and I London
mobile was the only girl that was like
hold onto yo let's go and rescue
Momo step the [ __ ] up oh yeah okay so
I'm not gonna vote yet I'm gonna go to
uh my boy Frankie
a hundred percent say like no questions
asked I don't like us you know at all
actually
it's Shay hey is there any particular
reason why you don't like her I mean she
just hasn't really done anything at all
like we didn't even get to see her do
anything real during their like
internships and whatnot I don't know I
guess it's a matter of personality like
she just we haven't really seen much
from her where sujes like probably the
second most screen time girl I feel like
it seems more yeah like I would feel
like in the scenes that Amin has been in
she usually shines for me like even
though like they aren't like they're so
few and far between but when they do
give her spotlight usually like even if
she's in like a group shot she's usually
the one that I'm focused on cuz she's
like the most like the biggest
personality they're like she's always
the one like with the most not to say
but like the most action going on yeah
and then Julie we have very different
personalities like yeah but like totally
compatible as being friends but they
yeah um anyways if you won all right
well obviously the alien queen probably
wins looks wise but we can't count that
I feel like she she has thrived a little
bit in her screen time I like her she
was like top eight in the tournament arc
but obviously honestly I'm have to go
with sue you is she's not only as she
receives a lot more screen time but she
is I think she is like been spot on in
the screen time she has gotten she's
just a very lovable character like how
can you not like sue you at all and I
feel like I could see it changing as
time goes on and the alien queen gets
more gets more screentime or whatever
but for now like I'm gonna have to go
with sue you
it's tough bird doo-doo in itself to me
oh man oh man well my brother goals I
just made up through your video on the
channel but I just find me a more
interesting model I just like I respect
you but like I don't mind frogs but I'm
not like huge frog dude or as me not
think it's pre loot more interesting huh
no bricks at the t-shirt oh no I just
think Mina is more interesting I think
she's like more of a cool person to
chill with yeah and I didn't like to
assault I'm gonna show you guys my room
thing I thought that was wack so my vote
has to go to the alien queen Wow woo
I'm Harry Smith and he just sleeps like
baby I mean I didn't I like I was gonna
vote her out of the next one but I just
really thought like everyone to be like
oh yeah for sure
the next one's more - oh it's not it's
really hard I like both of them anyway
yeah Rafi is a public action guys
Mina one though this one unexpected but
it happens you know if you if you are
upset by this message knocks talk one
Twitter next round next airing we have
Kimiko toga the villain yonder a of your
dreams versus may have sumit the genius
awesome inventor girl who we need to see
more of damnit why don't agree this
woman like we need more of this
character she's such a character with so
much potential
goddamnit yeah it's a tough one this is
a tough one boy both of them stepped on
me being drunk you started to come I'm
curious is a force pulsing it's not
tough I wonder if ur gonna vote for the
same person
on the count of three you both say who
you're thinking of three two one mega
what
I don't like you Andres at all I thought
urging the tournament was the highlight
of the tournament
it was so funny watching their sales
pitch like what they're like with their
different equipment duper gear yeah I
thought it was so funny I don't get
through this round I'm gonna have a
nervous breakdown just so I it's not I'm
not responsible later okay
so my personal thoughts are Tolga is
interesting but I prefer to kind of
young then and it will kill other people
for you not kill you to drink your blood
or she won't kill you if like she'll
well I mean you have to be like ultra
badass for her to be like yeah she's
like people that are beat up right yeah
eat stain you know I would willingly let
both of these characters like step on me
if that's like that totally okay you
know what to each his own I personally
really like me I like that she's a
brilliant inventor I think she's a cool
character like very like confident and
stuff and it just like makes deco feel
like a little [ __ ] so yeah after go
with my girl may [ __ ] you've having a
bit of a breakdown right now like it's
okay cuz I like it's it's a same
situation where I'm like I like them
both for different reasons
are we okay define best girl because
that like fit um whoever you like better
straight up want to see on screen more
may understand is so cool okay since
toca started actually like being a part
of the show like my red tube my YouTube
feed has just been like clogged by
people talking about her and just like
clips from her like I
because I would willingly let her stab
me write me fight oh yeah fine but like
if you were to hang out with one of them
I heard you'd still be talking like
because I'm like I'm a is an [ __ ]
completely their bank yeah you guys at
this pink hair thing I don't know
speaking of pink hair
I would definitely hang out with a
yandere that's like zero to stop yeah oh
god there is like she might kill us both
somehow so I don't know man
given well I'm not like genius we use
the tournament like uber tiser stuff I
thought that was amazing
no I like at the same time I was still
salty she took advantage of my boy eita
and how cool she made it look like a
fool like what no eat is a good boy he's
a good boy he didn't arc on them no III
know I'm just saying it as like okay I
was like not easy to book just kind of
like he's like a goody two-shoes guy I
know I love him he's great all right so
we got anime dude are you going for toga
oh I mean we all love a girl that's a
little off her rockers that's a given
but at the same time I like seeing part
of the hero course getting development
and may and she's just such a fun
character like he made the turn 'mark
what it was Friday it's gonna straight
up these blokes you want to know what
the sickest thing about this is is when
we were talking earlier about how some
of these pairings like are bad for the
early stages I was thinking like the
most [ __ ] up thing is that toga and
frothy were on the same side I thought
that they shouldn't even be on the same
side cuz it's gonna come down to those
two you realize mater right yeah my boy
Bosko says so far so good I agree with
you my man oh we got we got you
and may in the next round
also cami from the manga doesn't get
enough screen time yet for to be in this
bracket of someone in the chat asked
about her next round we have midnight
versus mount lady two beautiful ladies
from this role gotta say both of these
girls are very very intriguing tens out
of tens yeah that's why he made the
rules but what they are exactly yeah you
can't vote on looks like I know but like
both of them even looks like all of them
are really that's what I was saying
they'd both be like towards top of the
bracket you didn't make those rules yeah
that's a big night's work again with her
scent yeah with her laughs yeah
she has like scent powers and the other
one is like mountain lady's is changing
sighs yeah well she can only go big and
small and go back to normal she can like
control her size
hmm yeah she's not like yeah she's not
like Ant Man no yeah yeah um everybody
just thickness her big form is
definitely the thickest around yeah
mm-hmm um I also appreciate that like
like mat lady when she's introduced
you're like oh okay she's like this is
all for the camera bah bah blah like
she's not really interested in being a
hero but she totally yeah she totally
takes one for the team twice like she's
there for the real for one fight and she
saves the kids by getting in the way at
one point
yeah risk that was her at any moment
yeah that that frigate and it looked
like that looked like it hurt she took
it right in the face yeah this is the
one of those things where if we were
looking at looks you know still feeling
like men I'm into BDSM big night all the
way guy
Midnight's a character I want to see
more of only because like all I know
about her is she's like the hot teacher
like that's and the hot skillet
your cockamamie teacher I loved her
exchange with Mina I thought that was
hilarious yeah she was little like she
legitimately did want him to like step
up which I was like yay like she
actually is a teacher she's like the
only one who hasn't been like boom and
that's a she's like no good proud of you
yeah so who's gonna vote here because I
I'm very conflicted on these I guess
I'll go ahead and vote first cuz I hate
being the freakin decisions but uh I
don't know midnight seems like a cool
character I would definitely like to see
more of her but mount Lady did help to
rescue my boy Baca goat so goat yeah so
I think I'm gonna have to give it to her
even though she has a few of those
moments where she like takes advantage
of her popularity and whatnot to get
free stuff but does have the best
personality but I'm still going to give
it to her okay so we have one vote for
my lady I was a party with both of these
people oh yeah
like I think they both be like like
they'd be like the type of girls like
let's go out on the town and you'd have
a good time but I I have to give it to
Mount lady cuz like I was legitimately
wanting to give it to midnight but I I
don't she hasn't it's it's the same say
it's like the MENA situation where like
yeah Midnight's been around more I guess
but like Mount lady leaves more of an
impression on you okay so yeah I can go
to give it to Mount lady too yeah okay
so that's two bullets front lady my vote
won't go to midnight because while I do
like mountain lady she is the thickest
she's the midnight to me is just she's
so like interesting like she's the like
I'm like I'm like her whole confidence I
like her whole like like doesn't let
herself be pushed around messy world of
girls like you mean it up she's like oh
yeah break it off so I think that
midnight is more intriguing to me right
now so I'm gonna go from that I don't
know to vote for from he go well I was a
pretty desired on Mount Lady until just
said the thing about her
st. bring it on the mean it so sure
that's so awesome
she's a good teacher like a legitimately
like good I would have killed to have
got the cathedral mouth I had that type
of teacher now get him oh yeah you wish
we all good I was gonna say I'm like no
I did not
it's like you've been sweet purposely
not and Shannon yeah I guess I'll still
give it to mountain lady on the basis
that she reminds me of Margaery Tyrell
from Game of Thrones who's the best
character of all time she is kind of
like Marjorie yeah she is yeah
Marjorie's the best so yep I'll do mount
lady yeah I don't have to vote I didn't
really know what I wanted I had no clue
about my mom lady wins
I accept graciously defeat and Frankie
said I do my lady 20 and I was like hmm
I mean hey no judgment here all right so
mount lady moves on and next we have
she butter or well I wonder what is her
name
Joseph rapper vine girl versus Momo wine
girl versus this Camaro alright so we I
think we all agree on Momo right yeah
yeah it's definitely more low-key but is
fine you but eyes her name but he's
behind but Momo is just amazing that's
just dirty Briggs why'd you gotta put
her up against the best girl flawless my
favorite you know well someone has to go
against normal the chat is just mama you
gotta be mone think we need mole I
originally had no mobile again so choco
but I want to do a chocolate barfi that
way we all agree Momo yeah yeah cool
yeah but people like the vines but rip
vine we're in the next matchup we have
inko midoriya AKA de coos mom versus
Yaka Yaka and i will start this off 100%
Becca's mom no you're better King that
that coos mom or choco is fine she's
huge she's a nice person
but she's in it for the money he's a
average type girl nothing too special
about her
whereas de Guzman is a dedicated single
mom you know that her husband is out
there up to some shady [ __ ] and she said
for him you know she's covering for I
want to know what it is down to cover
she's raising deku she's standing up to
even all nights when she needs to love
her definitely income like but like not
as a best girl like sometimes it is it's
the mom versus the love interests that
I'm torn
it's like I mean like I get it like I
understand where it's coming from
mm-hmm um I have to give it to her Erica
though um thank you know only because
you're welcome because like I actually
almost appreciate that she's in it for
the money cuz it was refreshing like it
like well like you said like ITA's just
like no superheroes and deckers like I
won't be a hero I got protect the
people's smiles and [ __ ] and butter our
cos like nah dude I need to get paid my
family's poor she's more grounded
realistic than yeah exactly I was like
that's cool I like that and like her
fight with bak ago was Joe yeah like I I
don't know I'm just I'm more on on her
side like one way to look at it and the
other way to look at it is that where a
guy has no virtue she's not good for
this mean I get it for the moral
conviction and stayin play her alive if
he had the chance
he would absolutely just play which
makes it really breaks my heart unless
you know you know I'll be very auto
character if life's thing needs records
like I would kill you but you are so
cute
exactly just like damn I just
yeah I'm gonna pass that's the thing
about standing his convictions like
they're understandable but the same time
he's a villain
you can't go based on those in America
or you're gonna be the villain no I know
but I just remind personally like I
would do it I wouldn't do anything to
harm her I think she's adorable but I
just love that was mom in the chat Oh
animatic of course she's gonna vote for
the MILF how dare you a mother I'd love
to hug like to thank for raising such a
good boy that coos mom's got it going on
yes I was Oliver
wiglesworth great last name donate it to
say mole mole toga Kendall and milady
qual those are his legs how can i watch
too much dojin don't you read dojin I
saw that in the shadows like wait what
hey you could do whatever you want you
could do it everyone with those words
bro
I don't read the words nice I just look
all right so we got one for duck who's
mom that's me
one for Veronica from Jojo rest of you
guys seem to be like hiding over there
I'm gonna go ahead and say that Dec
whose mom is probably the best mom she's
a great loving mother single mother and
that scene where she's pretending to be
in trouble when Deku comes in the door
to rescue her that's just adorable
melted my heart I'm here same time I'm
have to go with you raka for my vote I
like her personality she's fiery she's
competitive she's like the most
tomboyish grounded to reality girl in
the show and I'm gonna have to go
through baraka
I wouldn't say she's tomboy so I'd say
she's like sporty yeah they probably a
better definition of it yeah
all right so we have two former anka one
for deck was mom yeah I'm looking for uh
Taraka I can't pronounce her name and
it's a love interest that I actually
like in anime and even though decas mom
is like awesome I feel I count you know
I not a mom don't have a kid can't
relate
much I don't like that's really nice and
heartwarming cool but like I'm here for
the fights that's a bit like it it's
funny cuz like the episode that passed
by recently reminded me why I'm like
she's a good mom but at the same time I
was like shut up like what she's like no
you can't go to UA ametropia sure your
face kind of funny about this matchup is
they kind of have similar quirks to like
a rocket can float stuff and they too is
mark or Decker's mom can just kind of
float small objects towards her I guess
it's Fairford to pass the first round
but I still think that that goos mom is
awesome and breaks that's okay man you
can vote for your car if we had a best
boy tournament you know would win
Todoroki because he's the best boy I
would even know her and put him on the
bracket III think you guys mean clearly
the sugar rush guy no he was clearly did
you guys think when they're all talking
to frothy and they're all like crying
except the door he's just like this is
stupid man
yeah you know even man [ __ ] important
news guy isn't that my own from the big
three manga character versus zero who
put her ear phone jacks
into the ears of two men at the same
time by force in the last episode so
that I was born it happened i mean e-to
moment yeah let's go Sam like is that
technically rape it's something yeah I
don't have a few of us I remember seeing
that like I don't know how I feel about
that it was better when she stabbed
Minetta in the eye like that looks like
a hurt yeah because he was he was
peeking in on them so you deserve it but
these guys didn't deserve it wasn't
girly on a side note like speaking of
things that don't deserve it did Bach
straight up like shakedown
what's-his-face for money in that
episode or am I crazy
no he took him behind the bush and he
made him stupid and then he asked him
how much it costs is what I think they
said yes they would get that information
and that no I used his own money is what
I think it said Oh instead he said I'm a
cheap guy so like I don't like having to
do it so oh ok yeah cuz I was like what
the hell happened in that episode
yeah I thought Bongo just kicked his ass
change the mood and in the end we won it
all at once that's funny
anyway back to the bracket I gotta go
with zero cuz I don't know the other
character yet yeah I mean I think that
we don't know enough about Ned Judah yet
to say that she's better than zero so
I'll go with zero i'm not the greatest
fan of her but she's cool and yeah i
just want to say to whoever in the chat
set that invisible girl is thick good
the thickest clearly yeah i'm one for
your earphone jack euro i don't remember
who the other person is it yeah so
that's that's an interesting point if
you caught up on the manga beyond you
remember her much but major desk work is
often way better than i would like you
know I would want to be in like a rock
band with zero you would that's yeah
would you rather I would only be the
drummer I can see it well that's my job
I can't believe that's Mackinaw job has
to be like I'd have to play ukulele in
the back by myself sad the only ukulele
player in a death metal band ma'am now
real going with me it'll draw my memory
yeah don't you remember it honestly it's
like I read the manga I don't remember
it yeah she can use like chakras let it
fly and stuff mmm cool
yeah jeera yeah here
alright so Giro is this thing
playing engine then we have Kendall from
class 1 be against invisible girl from
class 1a and I'm gonna start us off
right away with Kendall and whistle girl
doesn't do [ __ ]
Kendall actually I love how she like
puts our boy NATO in line you know so
she risked her life to defeat the
villains whereas where was Invisible
Girl
where was Tohru she was passed out
somewhere come on
Tohru is the best girl of a total I'm
not even gonna go there but Tohru is no
hey hey no is nothing Tohru was it's
right alongside Todoroki in the very
first time they fought villains so alike
she was right there by the long I'm side
everybody you could argue that Toro was
technically at every fight it was just
completely exactly you just didn't see
her for the bracket how we're gonna put
a blank spot um I gotta give it to
Kendall - I'm so glad somebody else said
kendo even if she loses I'm like no good
adamak he's a smart [ __ ] guy and she
puts in the work she looks like [ __ ]
chun-li which is rad she's just cool
okay I like her she's cool let's take
[ __ ] she's brave for sure
she should be in class Blake it should
be reversed she should be in class one
day she's badass I like her Korra was
easier to draw
yes sure yeah no she's great I love
kendo she's just a badass so let's have
Kendall advance geist haven't seen
enough of Tohru oh my god I like that
all the the typical my hero academia
best girls conduct were you sorry we're
not your typical filthy casual if you
know exactly
oh we're men of culture I mean I would
have voted for Invisible Girl but come
on the first round to meso I wouldn't
call you men of culture but Oh Rocky
what about you my friend or not
definitely kendo I won't get cool so we
go ahead and really do anything yeah
so we agree excellent so kendo is
through and then we have the pussycat
showdown
Mandalay versus pixie Bob why you got to
make me choose between my girls Mandalay
is like by the way hurt mandalas quercus
to telepathically communicate with
others
mixie Bob's quirk is to control the
earth she's basically an earthbender
also tossing pixie bob is a thirsty 31
year old woman and I love and yeah even
though it's double standards because
people like owe me this is such a
pervert and then fixie bob is like oh
when you guys are a little older get at
me and I was like oh that's so cool like
yeah but I can get this super double
said that I remember like seeing that
thinking like awesome and I had to
rewrite all my thoughts on it because I
was like that's super not fair I like
Manila now yeah exactly that's double
standards what I definitely also will go
for a pixie Bob because I'm just
intrigued by a thirsty 31 year old woman
yep I don't know
I think the recurring theme for this has
been just like spike Spiegel's like I
love a woman who can kick my ass and I
got to give it to pixie Bob I feel like
pixie Bob would whup my ass and she's
also fun to hang out with and she's an
earthbender she's like Toph yeah I'm
gonna have to go with Mandalay thank you
I like pixie Bob and but like you said
she's thirsty that's okay and everything
but she seems a little bit too thirsty
like there's some stuff we ain't seeing
there's the reason for single bear point
she does seem a little admittedly like
temperate temperamental uh-huh but I
kind of like that you know Mandalay
seems like you were all over a deck use
mom stuff for being such a great mom
like I think Mandalay is doing a pretty
decent job with Kota she's taking him in
since his parents died oh I'm happy and
she's like young itself is her kid but
she's still being very responsible so to
her votes for pixie Bob bite me yes Jo
Jo one thought-out vote for Amanda Leigh
so we still have Briggs and fry
need to go well I'll go with Mandalay
because honestly I didn't even remember
Pixy Bob's name until you guys said it
oh I did not really leave much of an
impression on me at all where I like
Mandalay a lot that's right
Mandalay is really cool like I like but
like pretty much all the Pussycats I'm
like yes I am actually kind of shocked
ragdolls not on here
yeah first light thing rag doll has been
around much you know it's true yeah
kidnapped and then it's like what 15
slots for the first fourteen I knew
exactly like or we more or less knew who
we wanted and we're like okay let's put
the pixie yeah whatever for the last two
well even right dot like they hand wave
away what happened to her like in like a
like in between card or they're like oh
by the way like this cuz again I didn't
read the manga so I just saw like in
between when they were cutting between
commercials they're like by the way rag
dolls quark got taken away to it like
she you know she was the number 32 hero
and stuff and she had to resign just
like oh my didn't it's like I would have
liked to have seen that show what the
hell bones yeah I know yeah
okay so Briggs it's up to you we have to
form an alliance you for pixie Bob I
kind of I just feel for pixie Bob
despite Frankie for not haha me I'm not
a man of culture guys I'm so split
between these two I mean that for one to
be more decisive Bria happy a man be a
man only person to vote for me to be
honest
like I thought Togo gonna win for sure
just like from all the fan art you see
over hmm
yeah I'm at nothing with my head here
guys hey man I could appreciate
aesthetics of people and pixie Bob's got
it going on to the round that Serbia
never gets in to the world in the World
Cup let's do this we have Nina versus
may soft by like may more I think I like
me more she's all think she's they're
both pink but may is like like I said a
brilliant genius marketing genius I just
attention that I want to see more of her
in the manga and the show that's
probably why I like her thinks I'm like
in marketing or sales and stuff and that
was [ __ ] brilliant what she did at
the tournament I agree I'm attracted to
intelligence and the alien queen girl
always scores like last and all of her
tests and everything and she's got a
Donna yeah she's kind of a but she's so
fun yeah she is fun but I'm have to go
with me that's fair um so that's two for
me I think are three for me I think
majors one I'm gonna vote for me too
sure feel the deal I just I yeah cuz I
was like I'm gonna go for me too knowing
she's gonna lose but yeah I like I love
me but like Mina would be so cool to
hang out with she'd be so fun
I think her character has a lot of
potential for westward yeah yeah he does
get a little bit more screen time oh for
sure I'm sure she will and like may may
as a character I want like I like I'm
excited for her to be like the cue of
like the my hero world where she just
like makes all this cool tech for
everybody everybody yeah yeah but I want
to see more of her and like actually
establish for more as a character yeah
definitely and like if you ask me if you
want to see more of Mina or may well I
like me now it's all based on that I
wanna see you know what yeah that's fair
actually it was funny I think I like me
more if I would want to see more of Mina
that makes sense I think I she liked
making me that one impression like I
[ __ ] love you like that hilarious and
like genius and then like Mina is like
an overall better personality in my
opinion and then I'd want to see more of
her as a character that make sense
that's fair yeah so where we have the
votes because I lost rod May 1 it's like
we have 4 to 1
okay so May is through now we have mount
lady versus Momo mouth lady you know
at all but Momo is brilliant Momo is
bold no context awesome quirk Momo for
me you would ask me like in season one
this would be a very different answer
but yeah denotes this Momo okay cool
that wasn't too hard now we have zero
versus Yaka and this I think it's the
one that Jojo is gonna be tortured by
yeah this sucks this really sucks
ah no even though I wouldn't against or
chuckle in the first round I feel like I
would just know more about her than Gero
Gero it's just kind of been too
mysterious and like it kind of just like
in the background so for that reason I
will go with hooter our kind this one
come on love Kira I do well she's a rock
star
you know she's the girl at the rock show
it's a quote blink-182 um uh okay I love
both of them I like that America's like
the girl next door but she's also like
tough and her own right and Giro's like
this badass like rock star um I gotta
give it to Jiro like she's just more
she's just she's more like she's another
character I want to see more of because
we already know a lot about Erica but
Jarrell like I like seeing like her
backstory like she's like the daughter
of a big rock star and she kind of has
this cool thing with lightning boy going
on and she's just like her own unless
use her own character like I almost feel
like instead of being a superhero she
should have been like a rock star
yeah like this thing where she just
laughed up because of this dopey quirk
yeah exactly yeah that was funny yeah
okay so we have one or charcoal and one
zero it's getting intense guys I want to
go to anime do because I feel like he's
conflicted I am I'm looking at the chat
I think I feel like everybody's saying
Jiro but at the same time like you guys
were saying she's more of a background
character and I haven't really seen
enough of her
put her over or raka who's been amazing
every time she's on screen like I said
she's very competitive I like seeing
that her fight with Bach ago was top
tier I think I'm have to go with Haruka
oh I was disappointed by her performance
against space hero 13 her and I yeah an
emotional thing it's like he distracted
her on purpose no that was totally on
purpose I love that I love that kid
I don't care what anyone says yeah
exactly
yeah Rock'em might die if I pull this
off but like I'll win though we die
exactly all right okay so we have to or
chuckles right one zero on to Franchi
I'm gonna go with zero
yeah two two two very interesting and
Lord briga comes into relief ruin floppy
day once more three go - what that
reference oh it's a taco I'd only seen
the hype behind here
Oh so basically Frankie will never come
back again to the rank of answers yeah
oh she played rock music I think she's
cool yeah well like I can't give her my
vote overall choco who's I've done so
many cool things I like her so much more
that's like a she she's a cool girl yeah
yeah sorry okay sorry uh froggy man it's
not personal it's personal it might be
person about how he's gonna get personal
well that again Briggs doesn't
appreciate the greatness of Todoroki so
you can't take him too seriously
Wow yeah yeah Briggs I got you there oh
oh we got kendo versus pixie Bob pixie
Bob interesting caught pinkie perhaps
about Kent down cooler more about us so
far well we know more about her to be
fair but just personality-wise I like
her more
I feel like Ken doesn't know my
personality was and just for that I
don't have to put her over pixie Bobby
we haven't seen much of besides her
being well too thirsty and little
thirsty
great work I think yeah I like how she
uses her quark it's a very creative way
or like how she did and placed in the
training camp part yeah I was cool um
yeah I got to give it's kendo cuz she's
like Momo but like not a rich valley
girl like she just like a good person
like that's and I like that I appreciate
that say I'm gonna give it to Kenda and
Kendall and Momo together at mommy's
this make you a woman
hero kind of placement please yeah
there were only worse yeah she's chosen
cuz it looks I think yes she did I was
like okay that's fair also can those
quirk is to her get huge hands that she
couldn't be the [ __ ] yes it's me go man
okay so we're in the semifinals here we
have mobile versus May right yeah um
Momo yeah ma
hailey should we talk about mom a little
bit or like oh but let me stress suit
like usually like in Shonen whenever I
see like that the hot girl is
everybody's best girl I'm like I bet you
she has no personality
she's solely the hot girl Momo has so
much [ __ ] personality and is also the
hot one
like holy [ __ ] that's awesome I honestly
don't even think Momo is the most
attractive physically or anything but
she's just it's just a personality she
got the booty just like she has it she
has looks but at the same time I'm
saying the personality puts her over the
top she's great yeah just Google I mean
guys come on
Sam anyway yeah I think like I love may
have praised her a lot but we just
haven't seen enough of her to go up
against MoMA because we've gotten a lot
of almost character development and
personality and if we see more of May
and we see more development at stuff and
relationship development between her and
whoever I would love to see that but
until then I think Mobile has to go
through and then we can talk about in
the finals we can talk about Momo versus
whoever yeah for sure
by the way pecking 101 was here he would
have also said normal all the way so
there you go I wonder who Knox would say
so I'm some stupid invisible girl big
girl although yeah he would have in neon
over night is you know she might be the
most beautiful woman you've ever seen
invisible girl is awesome I she's like
my number two all right so on the other
side we have the final two are or
charcoal versus Kendall hmm I'm
reserving my vote for the end meet Oh
with Briggs meter and oh yeah Briggs too
bad oh yeah I don't know five
micrometers my like we didn't know it's
not okay um well it doesn't really
matter it's all part of Lord brickles
plan I figured you out Frankie I know
you're gonna vote for Ted but my actual
vote was gonna be for a Chaka I'm just
playing okay
like I like Kendall I do but I can't
like her so much like you know chocolate
done way more things in my opinion and
I'm a huge fan of otaku I myself am NOT
a huge fan of chocolate I don't like her
cuz you can't not like her she's super
nice and she's so kawaii and like all
this stuff but I just think Kendall's
more interesting and more badass my
kendo man I also like yeah like because
to me it's I don't know it's tough
because I'm like blending waifu and best
girl in my head cuz I'm like I don't I
don't know I ship deku with otaku too
much to the point where I just see her
as like an extension cuz I'm like no
they're like a separate thing
I really don't know because I like her
but I just think kendos like a more
appropriate best girl hmm I don't know I
mean your thought process Jojo Chi
shipped them so much that I really like
yeah I want to both because of that
connection I really want to vote for her
- I like her by extension exactly that
that's where my head's at because I'm
like [ __ ]
I don't I don't know cuz I just yeah I
feel like kendo is more appropriate but
our Erica and Decker man they're so
great um I don't know give me time give
me time
oh we just want to say that a Lopez
donated $2 I believe and he or she but
probably he let's face it this is a desk
girl discussion blouse Nigeria and kami
kami
so again Adrienne Kevin we haven't seen
much of kami definitely looks like a
total like really interesting cool chick
but we've seen very briefly I don't say
too much but we've seen very little of
her in the actual manga so that's why I
wouldn't put her on this list because we
need to see more over mm-hmm okay so I
quoted Kendall Briggs we're okay do we
have any other votes
freaking out there Franchi one for
Kendall so it's two one oh my hand one
coming oh yeah you Briggs you did see it
okay
I don't know this is so hard
I don't know what to do oh this is rough
like you're high well your heart died
you part of the car it's Erica noise so
the decision is going to go to the anime
dude a que punakha fanboys 69 this is
really tough this way so it's tied right
now you're the decider my dude
damn what's the check I just say they're
like a total guys you enjoyed watching
the anime do have a mental breakdown be
sure to leave a like is that like
Detroit smash it boys United States
officer mash that not sure some Russia
smash it you know what I think I think
i'ma go kendo
she's such a great character and I know
we haven't seen a ton of her like we
need to see more but she's like starting
to get a little bit more screen time and
there's so much potential there Lord
Twigg Oh attract is the best girl once
franck he gets his way Briggs does not
oh my god no final surprise at Kendall
Kendall clearly a bum he did a great job
to be best girls I don't know what
heroes buck oh my god and now in the
finals we can actually debate why I love
Momo so much and the reason I think
Mama's best girl is yes she is rich but
the fact that she is rich doesn't define
her character like she lacks confidence
in many areas and has to develop as a
character she looks up to people like
Todoroki as like these you know great
heroes with so much potential and she
actually feels an inferiority complex
towards someone like tell Haraki so she
wants to be better and improve she's the
most intelligent character in the
classes her intelligence is six out of
five everybody so she's like her town
this is on par with like the principal
um Vanessa also she like I said was the
only girl in the whole class that was
down to go and rescue back role you know
she was down to do what needs to be done
and sometimes you can you gotta take
action so I think that Momo is
definitely best oh and of course she has
an amazing quirk like if you don't know
waifu status like she could make you
paste you what babe I'm hungry
but we don't necessarily mean to talk
about wife was that as this reduces best
barrel but yeah it's like babe can I get
four kilos of pure gold
sure but here's the thing though she
wouldn't do it
she's too morally right for that exactly
and I still get the plus to her it's
funny actually because that's an
interesting name because because she's
rich she doesn't need to do stuff like
to survive you know create money or
wealth or whatever so that kind of goes
well with her core cause if she was like
before she might have been tempted to
star just like making artificial money
and all this kind of stuff
which could have bound her in legal
troubles don't have the economy and all
that stuff so I think she's a very
interesting character she's great yeah I
love mama oh one thing we have all the
reasons that Anna Mac just outlined
whenever I'm going for best girl or when
I'm trying to decide the factors to make
a waifu or whatever it is usually
intelligence is one of the top things I
look at and then to self-confidence like
how they carry themselves and three
character development yeah definitely
has the intelligence but she actually
starts out with basically like no
self-confidence once she compares
herself to Todoroki and loses early in
the tournament but the character
development takes care of that and it
she's we see are starting to get more
and more confident as the series goes on
so just potential wise and what she's
gonna be by the end I think there's no
doubt that Momo's by far the best girl
yeah well especially like during the
like the the training are not training
what would you call it the exam mark she
stepped right the hell up hmm and then
followed that up with going to say Bach
ago like I
that's like main character levels of
like progression for a side character
yeah yeah oh is is great
that's a [ __ ] that that's a compliment
to horikoshi big-time because like all
the characters gets much less screen
time than like ultracal right yeah bill
manages to be like center stage yeah for
sure
ooh and the only thing I don't like one
moment that he looks up to Todoroki
because like who likes Todoroki of the
bad
amazing Clerk I love that she's so smart
but still tries to like constantly
improve and get better like she's
literally best girl she's yeah just so
you know next anime north I'm gonna
dress up like Todoroki and I'm just
gonna look around dress the PES [ __ ]
what's a dad dave has to happen now I
have the video that yeah okay and ever
and ever yeah yeah yeah yeah that won't
be a later sound film that just like
history of misery just like not only am
i disappointed in Jojo I'm disappointed
in my cosplay son
I know go with Mama awesome girl and
nygma Prince donated $5 to say Momo is
just an amazing character superb cleric
awesome chemistry with the class looks
up the best boy short dog text bricks
I love Briggs water for her to even
though she looks up to him and they're
totally gonna end up together and very
appealing to look at as well so yes I
agree
hundred percent Momo is awesome yep what
the [ __ ] is this whole [ __ ] if this was
between Momo and either frothy or toga
it would have been no question in my
mind there's been one of those two para
Butterfield thing you mean the people
that lost in the first round
no I personally expected both of them to
go further I thought that I would be the
only one that votes for like Nina or for
Mei so that's the same thing I'm
surprised that they didn't go further
because I guess we just have that group
of people here where we had that boy the
other way what idea there's like rocks I
think you say this bracket was very left
side heavy yeah like a fan base
sort of popularity vote that Franchi you
would have been up there man oh yeah yes
the left side is definitely a lot
stronger than the right side this was
definitely a very fun stream guys thank
you all for joining me again everyone
links are in the description everyone in
the chat thank you for everyone who
donated and joined and talk to us I like
everyone who says that Sholto is best
boyy I like hell even my boy Briggs
voted for sholto's girl so you know and
it ended up working out because of the
personalities that have felt left heavy
but for like my logic when I made the
bracket I was like okay we're gonna put
Momo on one side to you on another on
the same side and on the other side put
a choco and Giro just thinking like that
would like naturally work out and then
people's tastes just surprised me yeah
but I still think Becca's mom was
underage but still you know I I said it
was the best mom bracket she would've
won oh yeah another I have curious who
knocks talk of you'll see what water for
cuz he's always like just saying random
[ __ ] I'm saying I think you would have
forced Toro through all the way this is
I would've been right there with him to
know it would have been vine girl oh
yeah he was like yo you guys don't
appreciate the power vine girl yeah even
though she's up against Momo it's still
vine girl you would find a way no yeah
true we also thank you guys for joining
me thank you to people saying an
America's best girl oh you guys I am six
out of five in intelligence
whoo well as always we do this rank of a
thing every Thursday 5:00 p.m. Eastern
Time different guests switching things
that are now different topics again
check out everybody link in the
description great people with great
tastes although sometimes they have
weird stuff like not liking Soto but you
know we still love them and appreciate
them and yeah let's hang out again soon
until next time see us base gobble bang
bang